bowing once the pride of the skies is
facing further turbulence Irish budget
carrier Ryanair is the latest airline to
ground some of the Boeing 737 ng planes
in its fleet after finding cracks
between the wings and the fuselage on
three of their aircraft in the last
month 50 Boeing 737 ng planes from
various airlines around the world have
been grounded for the same fault the
small cracks appeared in what's called
the pickle Forks structures that help
secure the wings to the body of the
plane components that should last the
planes lifetime there are 7,000 Boeing
737 n G's flying worldwide currently
1,000 have been checked 50 have been
found to have these cracks this is
something Boeing is addressing of course
optics wise it's not a good look the 737
max still grounded worldwide and now
more problems with the current and
existing 737 the recalled planes are
earlier versions of Boeing 737 max
aircraft a model involved in two crashes
within five months that killed 346
people that entire fleet remained
grounded his investigations continue in
2014 al Jazeera exposed quality concerns
at Boeing South Carolina Factory in an
exclusive investigation using undercover
filming it looked at issues concerning
another of Boeing's aircraft the 787
dreamliner
now in a separate development a former
quality control engineer and edges that
some of the oxygen systems fitted on the
Dreamliner's could be faulty boeing
admits there was a problem with some
oxygen bottles in 2017 but say that was
addressed but travel sites are already
offering the option to exclude certain
aircraft from their searches boeing will
have to reconvince the flying public of
their safety charlie Angela al Jazeera